breaking now at three a shooting at
interstate 15 in downtown las vegas
thank you for joining us for this
special edition of eight news now at
three i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas let's get right out to
eight news now i-team's vanessa murphy
who is following the investigation from
the scene vanessa
metro police say one person is
recovering after being shot here on this
ramp we are at the northbound d street
ramp from interstate 15 and you can see
this truck with the windows which appear
to be shot out this is why this area is
blocked off police tell us no one is in
custody at this time this is an ongoing
and complex investigation police say the
shooting happened just after 11 this
morning so we're going on about four
hours here of this area being blocked
off again we want to let drivers know
this northbound d street ramp here at
i-15 is closed to traffic again police
say back here live one person is
recovering at umc after being shot they
are expected to survive reporting live
in downtown las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now